hello my name is inna braverman and i'm
the founder and ceo
of eco-wave power i believe
that wave power which can produce twice
the amount of electricity that the world
produces now is definitely
a great cause so how does the ecowa
power technology work
our floaters are going up and down with
the movement of the waves
and they're pushing a hydro cylinder
which transmits biodegradable fluid
into land located accumulators in the
accumulators a pressure is being built
the higher the weights the higher the
pressure this pressure is used to turn
the hydromotor which is turning the
generator
we decided to install onshore and near
shore
on existing man-made structures such as
spears
breakwaters jetties and other types of
mermaid structures
when the waves are too high for the
system to handle the floaters
automatically rise
above the water level and they stay in
the upward position
until the storm passes although my real
passion
is wave energy i truly believe that the
solution
for climate change and for the world's
problem is integrating
all renewable energy sources we need to
use solar
and wind and wave and any type of
renewable energy technology
in order to have a 100 renewable energy
friendly world
you